I think a lot of people think that like
they picture jail as what's on TV and in
the movies and it's like you know which
some of it yeah there's prison politics
and it's from prison to the county level
but the reality is is you know people do
their due diligence and and you know
they're not going to intentionally put a
Child In Harm's Way and hey make this
baloney sandwich I don't know I don't
know if you ever I don't know if you
watch I don't know if you watch this
show
bro I don't know if you've ever watched
this show Bob but I can tell you there's
people out there that definitely put
kids in arms
away the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
[Music]
today